most people in pakistan live along the
indus river it runs from the north to
the south and is an area prone to severe
monsoon flooding but this year's monsoon
rains are unprecedented affecting all
four of the country's provinces
if we look at how many homes have been
damaged this shows which districts are
the worst affected the darker areas have
the greatest damage up to
000 130.000 have been damaged in these
different districts
now satellite imagery shows the extent
of the flooding on the left here
villages along a section of the indus
river that was back in march this is the
same location now look completely
submerged and that's why the navy has
been brought in to help these remote
rural areas
global warming is being blamed let's
just consider glaciers there are over
7000 in pakistan that's more than
anywhere else outside the polar regions
but rising temperatures are causing
increasing glacial melt which in turn is
causing flooding
and that isn't the only problem climate
change is increasing the intensity the
frequency and the duration of monsoon
rainfalls this heat map shows how much
rain will fall during this year's
monsoon and it's all above normal levels
but particularly in the darker blue
areas the sindh and the punjab provinces
and this chart gives us a sense of how
vulnerable pakistan is to climate change
it shows how much hotter the country
could get the two lines show the
projected number of hot days that's days
over 35 degrees that pakistan could see
over the next 80 years the blue line is
the best case scenario that's if rapid
global action is taken to cut greenhouse
gas emissions but if little action is
taken the orange line here shows the
worst case scenario the number of hot
days leaps from just under
130 to around 180
a year and that could be catastrophic
causing drought
failing crops and significant problems
with water supplies